[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by
my co-host dr greg sadler and today
we're talking about lessons we learned
from stoicon 2021 and you might say well
what what's that you know stoicon i
haven't heard of that if you're one of
our listeners you might have but there's
a good chance that you haven't
so i think something that we have to
start with is answering the question
what's stoic on and why should we be
interested in it
and you know
if you go to other cons or you go to um
other big gatherings like that i think
it's it's pretty easy to relate to it's
a conference or convention
sort of like going to comic-con or
midwest gaming classic or the big auto
show or stuff like that
and it's uh for people that are
interested in stoicism and we're going
to tell you more about that
in just a bit
anything else that you think we ought to
add right off the bat dan
well uh part of this is i we were
participants we were definitely there to
see all the things but specifically
greg and andy were the uh hosts of this
last year's stoicon and so not only is
this a
kind of like a retrospective of some of
the topics that went on but also of the
whole process of like what it goes into
to make an international conference on
you know a philosophy topic yeah
so you've gone to other cons right do
you think it's different when it's
philosophy oriented than when it's
something that probably has a
a wider footprint you know if you think
about comic-con for example
so stoicon is like a pebble compared to
the boulder that god
would be
um so
is is it because it's a
it's not really just an academic thing
there's a lot of popular speakers there
but um
there's definitely not like a um
a merch alley
uh
that you see in a lot of like
the more
popular cons you know
there's each con has you know certain
similarities and they'll all have the
their own little like lanes that we they
produce and yeah like it was definitely
not like a
um a conference that i've gotten that's
like really purely academic um
especially in like the computing space
i've been to a couple of really really
academic computing places and those are
you know it's all still a whole bunch of
nerds but it's still pretty stuffy yeah
i've gone to plenty of philosophy and
political science and even back when i
was an undergraduate a mathematics
conference where interestingly enough
the nsa was recruiting i believe oh
really yeah this is back in the early
90s and
they were viewed as like the dark side
within the mathematics community because
they were very interested in
cryptography so they would
they would recruit people and and i i
you know my uh
professor said you better watch out for
those people and i thought he was like
joking around but sure enough they were
they were there all dressed up and like
you know going around and introducing
themselves to people
uh so yeah but back to stoichion right
so we should we should
you know what is what is stoicism um
well you know it's an ancient philosophy
i think anybody who's a regular listener
to the show has heard me and dan talk
about it quite a bit
it's taught and discussed by authors all
over the ancient world
from the roman empire to the near east
and some of the big names that you might
have heard of or at least you know
encountered before cicero who's not
quite a stoic but really likes it seneca
who's definitely a stoic epictetus who
actually taught stoicism marcus aurelius
who applied it in his
imperial work i guess you could say
among a whole bunch of others and dan
and i are both
members and co-organizers of the
milwaukee stoic fellowship so you can
tell we have a
considerable interest in it uh what else
what else do we need to say about it
that it's been going on for
uh like stoicism has been around for you
know 23
400 years
going on here um that uh it has gone
through ebbs and flows throughout the
history it was very big from like 300 bc
to
uh maybe like uh 680 then it goes away
it comes back with the the
renaissance yeah yeah um
and then it went away again and now in
the last you know
60 80 years it's it's
gained a new renaissance itself yeah i
mean the last 20 years have been a huge
boom and i think a lot of that's
attributable to the internet
so you know we don't actually have any
clear numbers we can say pretty
confidently that there's at least
hundreds of thousands of people
in the present who are interested in and
practicing and applying stoicism but
there might be millions
and
we we don't even have a handle quite
frankly on how many groups or
organizations
online or in in person are doing and i'm
always finding out about new ones and
i'm the editor of stoicism today so
presumably i would you know have
some some insight into this but i'm
always being surprised by like well
there you know there's stoics in
indonesia doing this or there's a new
group in germany or
you know
pick whatever you want with that so
yeah and there there's a you know
a database the stoic fellowship or the
stoic fellowship dot com
um sorry stoic fellowship dot com know
the yeah um that you can at least find
some that might be around you but yeah
like
with the advent of the internet
especially things like
meetup that have allowed like for the
facilitation of finding people finding
these little communities yeah it's
really uh blowing up
yeah and we should mention too before we
go on further that there are some big
facebook stoicism groups and
reddit has its own
um subreddit for stoicism but that's not
the only place on reddit where you can
find people talking about stoic
philosophy
i know there were some other
uh forums as well linkedin has a few
i think yahoo groups had had a big stoic
forum that i've never participated in
but i think there's like
tens of thousands of people in that that
form so that gives you an idea about how
how interested people are in this and so
you know there's stoic khan
and in the last 10 years it's become a
place where you could go and meet other
people interested in stoicism
and hear talks by
some of the you know people who write
the important books or who do
a lot of other you know let's call it
stoic programming and you could
participate in in workshops and when it
was face-to-face you could even buy
books and some swag there there was no
as as dan was pointing out
what did you call it swag isle swag
merch alley merch alley yeah yeah there
wasn't anything quite like that it's not
like going to the wisconsin center and
going in that gigantic room
which is just filled with booths it
would just be like you know a couple
booths with a couple people sitting
there
but you know
it's still got some of that feel to it
and
i know for myself having gone to
three of the stoicons
one of the things i really liked about
it was getting to interact with people
outside of the sessions
yeah from my experience and those like
with the the stoicons i've actually gone
to i guess only the the midwest one but
also in other ones like um specifically
when i went to oculus connect
like being out there in the hallway and
just meeting these people and having
those one-on-one conversations yeah were
sometimes much more engaging than going
to the talks themselves especially
because a lot of the times the talks are
put up online afterwards true yeah uh
at philosophy conferences that's not
often the case unfortunately snowicon it
generally is now they've gotten savvy to
that
um you know it's it's interesting um
[Music]
would you say that
when you go to a convention a good part
of what you're looking for is not
just the stuff that's like the official
programming
it depends on the conference okay it
depends on the
like wheel uh stokon kind of like the
main programming seems to be
more interesting um and then the random
interactions that you have yeah
um but where something's like a little
bit more like phantom like there's lots
of things that the
participants in the
con are also doing ancillary so if you
got like a place where like um
costuming is really big then going out
and seeing everyone's cosplays is a
really big thing and once again the the
merch alley is another thing that is a
large draw and and at on developer
conferences for example um oculus
connect um a lot of the developers would
bring out their their their demos and
they they couldn't quite get onto
one of the stages but they're like here
here's my newest working so you get to
see all these things that are you know
still in production and people are
working within tinkering with yeah
it's like an inside look right
right yeah that sounds pretty cool
so going back to stoicon there's there's
a history there and we're going to run
through it like super quick so we can
get to some of the lessons that we
learned the very first conference that
was put on
uh which wasn't quite stoicon was at the
university exeter in great britain and
that was in 2012 and that was kind of
it was thrown together it was a bunch of
psychotherapists and academics and and a
few other people and i think there were
maybe 70 people attending it
and they they thought oh this is great
this you know there's so much
interesting stuff going on here and
that's when they put together the first
live as a stoic week which was now has
become like an annual
course and the very first official
stoicon was in 2013
in london and there are some videos
available on the uh there's a modern
stoicism youtube channel and we'll put a
link to that
in the uh the show notes and it was the
same core group and that would
eventually become the stoicism today and
then later it became called modern
stoicism organization and it really took
off it got a lot of um press people were
like what's this all about
who you know who's interested in
stoicism and so they did it there in
london for
three years and then i i myself got
involved when it moved to new york city
in 2016
so it finally made it to a different
place
that was massimo pigliucci organizing it
assisted by
amy
valadares who actually helped out with
all all of the
stoicons until it went online
and then it was in toronto in 2017
donald robertson organized that one
moved back to london in 2018
john sellers organized that one and then
donald robertson took it to athens in in
greece
and i didn't make it to that one because
i i sure didn't want to try to fly to
athens in october
myself but you know it looked like it
was a pretty cool thing i i got to go to
new york city and toronto and london and
present
workshops and then in 2020 you know it
was supposed to be i think it was
supposed to be in toronto again
but colvin hit right so then we had well
what are we going to do and it turned
into an online conference
and it drew in like you know the big
stoic cons drew in at most 400 people
which is you know pretty sizable for um
this sort of event the online stoic on
the first one drew in 1400 people
and that's about what we had this year
as well so you know it's clearly you can
you can
serve a lot more people going online
and um
yeah as dan mentioned donald robertson
was was originally going to
run this year's one but needed to step
away
it turns out part of that is he's he's
built a an academy in athens that you
can you can read about online uh so they
they asked well who's going to organize
it and i talked with my my wife andy i
said should we do this and
she said yeah yeah we can do that so we
volunteered and we had some assistance
from philianoff our tech person and from
harold cobley
my co-editor at stoicism today who
organized the lightning talks but it was
pretty much us
me and andy doing as
uh much of it as we could and we had
some goals and one of the goals was to
make it as affordable as possible and to
make it more engaging you know online
conferences i i don't know you you
should weigh in on this dan because i
know you've done you do a lot of online
events
sometimes it's kind of tough to make
them really engaging for the audience so
we wanted to try to do that and then we
also wanted to make it as accessible to
people all over the world as possible
time zone issues make it tough for
people in some places you know
particularly
um east asia and australia and indonesia
um
but you know we we did have people from
all over the world participating in it
so that was that was kind of cool i mean
what do you think
how do you make a conference engaging
or what do you find engaging in online
events
was it the
spice of life is a little bit of you
know
for variability you know having to do
different things
um how regular talks having those um
panels are also good and you know on
interstitial something to kind of like
get your your blood flowing especially
if you're like sitting there the entire
time like getting doing something to get
someone up and kind of like
moving around a little bit can
definitely
uh be a help that's a good point so
maybe maybe conferences should have like
a
stretch time or we're gonna do some
exercises or i know you could put them
to i don't know some sort of stoic theme
or something like that
but you like when you're at a physical
conference you're walking between halls
to go and see the different talks that
you want to go see unless you have a
single hall
um
and there's no you're getting your butt
out of the seat
right right and so like there's a little
bit of physical and so if you can i
replicate that you know
just a little bit i can definitely help
because if there's a really long
conference that's on it you know once
you get onto hour four of thinking about
something that starts to you know we'll
get a little bit of charlie brown
[Laughter]
now for those of you who are too young
to remember that because they don't play
these shows that often anymore on tv
there used to be all these charlie brown
specials and the uh young kids who are
all the the main characters in charlie
brown whatever an adult would talk i
think it might have like been a trombone
or something right exactly yeah it was
like
wow
it's just intel unintelligible gibberish
right
right yeah and that i mean that happens
at conferences i i have a good friend
who is also a benedict and monk and he
he you know
he's about 20 years older than me and he
told me this about 10 years ago and when
we were at a conference at notre dame
university and he said i'm going to go
to these first two sessions and then
i'll see you later and i was like you're
not going to hang around for the rest
and he's like
after the first two two sessions i'm i'm
shot my brain can't take any more stuff
in
and so i just go out and like you know
check out the city or you know go back
to my room or
do something like that and i was like oh
well that's you know that's too bad and
then i found myself you know later on
when i was going to conferences
realizing that
maybe three or four talks
that's it for me and and maybe when i'm
his age it'll be down to two talks as
well
gotta pick and choose yeah exactly yeah
so
lessons right that's the the topic that
we're talking about lessons learned from
putting on stoicon and from the stoicon
itself from what people had to say
some of these are things that came out
of the discussions or the presentations
in the q a and some of these are things
that we just want to share with you that
we learned by organizing and putting on
the event and you might say well hey
dummies you should have known that ahead
of time but there's a lot of things we
have to learn by experience and so we
thought it you know it would be kind of
cool to to share these with you and i'll
i'll lead off with the first one
and this ties in with something dan has
already said
you have to build in breaks we we
thought that in order to make it a
really
um
high impact event and get as much in as
we could we would start it at like nine
o'clock central time
10 o'clock eastern and finish up around
four o'clock you know uh and so it was
event after event after event it would
be you know
a talk and then a panel and then a
workshop and we didn't we you know we
didn't really include breaks um
and so
we got
a really favorable feedback
you know almost uniformly positive
people really like the speakers
they really like the topics
they
liked the format
but the number one complaint that we had
uh was
you should have put in a lunch break or
put in a break somewhere you know like
bathroom breaks or you know like a you
know 10 minutes here and there
and
you know
when when i first heard that i was like
but anybody can get up at any time that
they want to it's an online conference
you can if you want to go off to the
bathroom for 10 minutes you can do that
nobody's stopping you it's not like
being you know
chained to the to the laptop or anything
like that and the funny thing that we uh
we heard after that was
nobody wanted to take themselves away
from the screen
there was what we call fomo fear of
missing out
and so
people did put themselves i'm not going
to say like at great risk health-wise or
something like that but you know they
they they made some sacrifices in terms
of
getting lunch or going to the bathroom
or walking around or stuff like that
because they were glued to the screen
and so in some ways it wasn't too much
of a good thing
but i guess you the lesson here is you
have to space out the good thing you
have you do have to like introduce some
breaks and say okay now we're gonna have
some down time
and there's probably a lot of ways to do
that
i i thought it might be we might lose
people if we
if we programmed in that sort of thing
but
i guess that's that's an important
lesson you know in a face-to-face
conference you really do have to build
in time in between sessions for people
to get from session a session
and generally there is some sort of
lunch break but everybody's there at the
same time when you're across time zones
you know lunch for us
would be
whatever whatever
people are having
around
six seven o'clock in in
great britain or
in europe or wherever else they happen
to be right
right
and so with that saying i think we
should take a break right about now
two
one okay and we're back um but
yeah i've also noticed this um
like not only just for like general like
getting up and and talking about that
you it's nice to have that little bit of
time to reflect on what you just heard
yeah if you go directly into another
talk then you're like it's
um
things kind of start to blend a little
bit and and i was having actually just
the same exact problem this week when i
was uh doing like a whole bunch of
interviews um
and i i had you know
eight candidates lined up in four hours
and back to back to back to back to back
and it was a marathon yeah and and i've
now learned that i need to have a couple
minutes between those otherwise i'm not
going to be able to
properly
uh take in the information that i just
took in from that interview were were
these face-to-face or were these online
yeah i i so what do you think i i would
my
suspicion would be that it's more
fatiguing to do it in the zoom
those back-to-back interviews than it
would be like if people were walking
into your hotel room and then you said
all right we're done get the hell out of
here you know
what do you think
uh yeah potentially because there's
always going to be that like that
transition time
you'll at least have like 60 seconds
and i'm like basically clicking off of
one and clicking on to another
yeah that makes that makes sense i i
have that happen you know when i'm
most of my clientele are not here in the
milwaukee area
and i do tutorials and philosophical
counseling and consulting and stuff like
that and sometimes they'll make the
mistake of lining up like one
hour block client after another
and
those are the days when i'm really wiped
out at the end
yeah
i know that feeling well yeah you know
i'll if you don't mind a little
digression here
you used to be in the hiring for
academic positions that they're you you
do the first round of interviews at the
big
annual conference so for philosophy it
was the american philosophical
association eastern conference which
was horrible because they'd schedule it
between christmas and new year so if you
were going for interviews you could say
like i'm gonna have zero time with my
family
and they would put you into this giant
ballroom
and
there would be like tables everywhere
and you would get your first round of
interviews these are not the on-campus
interviews this is just like the first
round where they they would probably
interview 16 people 16 candidates for
any given job and then they would
eliminate
all but anywhere from two to four of
them
and so people would be go in and they
would be you know you have to be here at
11 30 or you have to be here at uh 12 15
or whatever they they arranged it as and
you know everybody's uh sweating and
wearing their their fancy clothes that
they brought along with them and
uncomfortable and nervous about what's
going on
and uh you'd sit down at the table and
it's just like you know there's so much
noise in that room you can
it's hard to hear what the interviewers
are actually asking you and you got the
amount of time that you have and that's
it and if you're a candidate well that
that sucks right it's it's not a fun
experience
but it's a cattle call yeah but it's
even worse if you're an interviewer
because
you are there with you and your
colleagues and you you you've already
got a job right but you had to miss your
time with your family between christmas
and new year's
and you're there in philadelphia new
york wherever it happens to be that that
time uh eating hotel food and you know
sleeping at an uncomfortable bed and now
you have to interview 16 people for that
job and you might not just be
interviewing for one position you might
be interviewing for three so you might
have
50 people to interview in in those
several days you know
very unenviable position and after a
while i imagine your eyes just kind of
glaze over you know when people are
giving you their carefully scripted
answers to how are you gonna
are you gonna contribute to our
department you know
i imagine it's like that in corporate
hiring too you know
yeah uh
so let's uh come back to the start yeah
yeah um
uh we dealt with uh our break in this
digression
and and the next the next lesson is i
think a really interesting one and dan
got to see a lot more of that than i did
because i was emceeing so
i was focused on like trying to find
questions in the chat
um
dan you got to see a lot more of what
was going on
yeah i was
actively in that chat it was fun
uh
um so yeah it's like once again you have
you have the conference and you have the
speakers and then you have the side
conference the side conversations and
especially when it's an online chat it's
not just like little groups of people it
is everyone that's a definitely a brand
new thing that online conferences have
brought in yeah
because if you were it was a
face-to-face conference like somebody
could be doing a presentation and you
lean over to the person next to you and
you're like i think this person's full
of crap you know maybe maybe maybe they
don't know what they're talking about
haven't they read this book right but if
you do it in zoom and you write
something like that everybody can see it
right
and so you know there was a couple of
interesting conversations there was one
about the
um
what can we call like those fellow
members of the cosmos that i guess would
give um
a moral weight or a
consideration to and so like within
stoicism usually the thing that like
defines
um someone that has like moral
consideration is do they have this uh
ability to reason you know they might
not use it but they have the ability to
yeah um and so you know in the past
people have talked about can we extend
this to other like higher level primates
to dolphins to you know where are you
cutting that line but regardless of what
it is we now have this group of um
uh
people or
entities that have some sort of rational
capacity
and so what do you call those people
um
as a group and like what what is if
you're like thinking about like oh you
know we're american or something or
where um
yeah milwaukeeans or whatever what do
you call the the largest group possible
um and so someone came up with a
beautiful cosmo homies and i thought
that was great
um
and then i took that and i i turned into
cosmo kin yeah because it just seems a
little bit more
you know workable fellow residents of
the cosmos of yeah that's that that's a
cool idea
how i mean
would you this is a bit of a side topic
but would you want to draw a line
like in the animal world between
what we often call the higher animals
and then you know things like insects or
oysters or
you know would you say it's important if
we're talking about like
treating them
with
some sort of dignity and respect
do we have to show
that equally i mean you think about like
corvids crows and ravens and stuff like
that they're pretty well they're
amazingly smart we're finding out
um
and then you look at like you know the
average paper
wasp not so smart
yeah
so um i
i don't know and i don't know where the
line is the line is fuzzy okay um and
and i haven't
seen anyone present a really good
um
case of of how to make a test for that
yeah to define that line um i guess i
would consider uh a lot of the the great
apes to be um on one side of that line i
would consider
a lot of um
cephalopods so octopi
yep um to be um on
that right side of the line um but i
don't know about gorwin's corvettes are
very smart um
and what are they i think some of them
have like the the intelligence of like
what a two-year-old or something yeah
which is pretty good you know that's
pretty good i mean
and they they seem to have something
like culture because if you
mess with acro
you will be on that crow's
you know what list
and then after that crow's died you'll
still be on other crows lists
so somehow they've communicated what you
know what you look like you know
um
how you should be treated there's
something going on there you know and
you know do we want to call that
rationality
i don't know it really depends on how we
define it but that that's a cool side
topic that we didn't really talk about
kai whiting
and um
that was last year
leonidas they presented some stuff on
that in their presentation
but it wasn't it was only about like
extending um things to the environment
right it wasn't it wasn't about like
where do we draw the lines
um what else
do people talk about inside
conversations um so there's a big
ongoing conversation um which is uh
kind of like there is this distinction
within stoicism we have modern stoicism
and we have like traditional stoicism
and traditional stoicism has this very
you know strong theological foundation
um whereas a lot of modernism says
you can kind of
lay that on a number of different
foundations theological or not um and
but there are some people within the um
more traditional socialism uh that
were asserting basically that you can't
have socialism with without any sort of
god concept and so um yeah i guess if
you want to throw avatars into this
we've got uh maybe kai on one side and
like massimo on the other
yeah so so kai whiting and massimo
pigleyuchi massimo pigliucci very
famously is an atheist who
did a lot of stuff with the skeptic
community
more or less about 10 years ago i'd say
and he thinks that not only
not only do you not have to buy into
traditional notions of like a stoic god
who's not who's not like the
judeo-christian god it's
a very different conception but it's
still a god conception um
you don't you know you don't have to buy
into the notion of a providentially
ordered universe massimo seems to think
that
you don't have any good reason to think
that that's the case and so
it's reasonable to not believe that that
sort of stuff right so there'd be like a
modern stoicism should be
um
more or less atheistic
or at least agnostic right
right like you you if you're
theistic great you can know stick that
in there yeah if not
um there's there's he
oh
[Music]
he has a book in which he
um
outlines exactly that argument um
but i think it's that how to be a stoic
book right yeah yeah yeah you're right
thank you um and then um i guess
uh kai recently within the last year or
two has put out a paper in which he kind
of asserts on
that you
can't have i believe the gist is and i
hope i'm still manning him well enough
um
that the
uh to have virtue be the sole good um
one must have a providential god
yeah and so if you accept that then you
must also then accept some sort of
providential god
that's a strong claim you know
um
but yeah so there was the talk about the
conversation that was going on i got to
see a little bit of it and it seemed
like
it was um
it was certainly energetic but it didn't
see i didn't see anybody acting like a
jerk to anybody else did you uh
no
there might have been a couple of on
like assertions okay um but there was
definitely no like ad hominem you know
no one actually attacking someone's like
individual personhood or anything um
but there was there was definitely some
incredulity um going on with someone's
like what do you mean like yeah um
and so
i don't know um
it i don't know if it was the the pure
ideal of uh you know interlocutors you
know a la like you know uh a platonic
dialogue yeah well even in platonic
dialogues people get pretty
i wouldn't say
mean but they get heated and they say
they say stuff that maybe they would you
know rethink later on
um interestingly there's a dialogue
where socrates who is acting like a jerk
at this dialogue
gets told by the host
this is the gorgeous
he gets told by the host
that
he shouldn't get angry because he's
taking socrates
if he's he's
losing his temper that's why socrates is
saying that the things that he is
um
so you know it's it's hard to tell
exactly what's going on there but but
certainly if socrates can be
warned not to
go too far
[Music]
than anyone can exactly
yeah
uh
so um you know it was it was a lively
you know um there were like links to
papers and whatnot and and it's only so
useful to be in the middle of a
conversation and it's like oh here's
here's a you know 10-page paper on
philosophical paper go read that real
quick yeah
so i mean should there be limits on side
conversations like maybe nobody should
post you know substantive
uh papers that require you to like stop
listening to the actual speaker and
attend to them
um
like
i think like
it wasn't super useful because i i
there's no way you can continue that
conversation
on with that was like you gotta breathe
here's some homework to do yeah that's
like come back next week and we talk can
talk about that but i also was happy to
have it in the conversation because it's
like oh here is uh something that's a
deeper dive and if i wanted to i'm happy
to go and read into that you know if it
was like an actual physical conference
you could say to the person hey let's
you and me go outside we're not going to
beat each other up we're going to
actually talk about this and we'll leave
that speaker behind
we don't you know in an online
conversation we don't really have that
option but maybe it'd be cool if there
were
ways not to go into like breakout rooms
but like to follow up on the
conversation
later on maybe that's something that we
need to
figure out how we would um
create options for what do you think
yeah
um like they're breakout rooms and but i
don't know
those have to be done by by the people
who are running it though exactly and so
it would require some ability to
like connect with that person and then
make your own little breakout room yeah
um which at least for using the zoom
platform like we were um was not a
viable option yeah and and if you were
just to like say hey
um let's go
over here
um in this google chat or something here
here's the link for it
anybody could jump on that unless you're
like privately messaging the person
right so
that that might not be a good solution
either i don't really have a solution
myself but i think it's something worth
talking about and thinking about
so this is a
quick diatribe this reminds me of my
experiences um in vr chats good vr
channel you warned us that's going to be
a rant
um
uh
in vr chat there's ability to um
you you create new rooms and you you
make little portals and you get anyone
that you want can follow you through the
portal and so i kind of love this idea
of like virtually actually going outside
and you could like you could
uh end up in like you know edo period
japan um doesn't really matter yeah
and so on or you're in space or whatever
you want because it's vr and you can
create whatever you want um but i love
this idea of like being at a
maybe a stowe conference in a couple
years and we're all in vr doing that
we're all sitting around in a conference
and then it's like hey
i want to talk to you about this thing
over here and you open up a portal and
you just go to another
plane to physics plane of existence you
know actually i think that's
a really cool idea that we could have
a
vr stoic on
um
i you know i i don't know anything
anywhere near the tech that would be
required to to make it happen but
wouldn't it be cool instead of just like
seeing the head of a person
on a zoom thing
to
more or less feel like you're there
right
i'd love that
yeah it's the the
wish of like second life that's what
they tried to do but it was all through
your computer screen and just it's a
that's a really poor simulacrum
yeah uh yes
maybe now we could actually pull it off
yeah on you know
although uh it's going to
restrict the amount of people that could
be
direct participants that's true just
because the technology is still rather
new yeah so accessibility would be maybe
we would lose some of that yeah
maybe we do two like uh you know
two different kinds of things
although then then some people be like
well you know
we're we're the second-class citizens
you know so they they might not like
that
at the very least you could capture the
conference with uh uh in vr camera and
display that through youtube or whatever
yeah that would stream the game
yeah
yeah
um but let's get to some more lessons
yeah um so let's uh terminology is
always an issue
um
why is that
because people come up at least with the
very
uh those people who are very new to
stoicism
you're coming in with a colloquial
understanding of the word stoic for the
very first part and so this is kind of
like one of our that's the first line so
we'll try to
knock down is the difference between
little estosism and big estosis whereas
a little less is kind of you know your
stiff upper lip you're um
repressing your emotions type of idea
for stoicism whereas stoicism capital s
is the
philosophy as a way of life
and
has
some ideas that are like absolutely the
opposite of what you think with little
aesthosis
you know
even in ancient times the stoics got
criticized for introducing
a lot of new terminology or taking words
that were already there like virtue and
then like giving them a twist that was
different than how other people
were using the term so
this can be an obstacle i think for
newcomers and maybe maybe the lesson is
it's really important that we like tell
our
uh presenters or panelists hey listen
there's going to be a lot of newcomers
if you use a term like
the indifference right or a preferred
indifferent you've got to say what that
actually means or are you going to lose
people
what are some other ones that you would
say like these are really high potential
for losing part of the audience terms
anything else that comes to mind um
a lot of times like this is what we're
going to get into a little bit more but
just um when we talk about the dichotomy
of control all right very well defined
that um
um
you know what good and bad are are on
true or also tricky within stosis yeah
yeah
um i don't know anything else come to
your mind i was thinking actually about
like when people use um
greek or latin terminology
when they don't actually need to like
you know it sounds really cool to say
pray matatazio malorum
but if somebody's coming in for the
first time if they're if they don't even
they haven't studied any stoicism they
just heard about stoicon and they're
like yeah i can i can do this on a
saturday afternoon and they hear you
like throwing out this latin or greek
lingo and they don't know what it means
i mean i'm not just i'm not saying you
can't use terms like that but but they
have to be they have to be explained
they have to be
characterized
because another way of talking about
that is negative visualization you know
or
more literally thinking about bad things
before they happen um
so i don't you know i don't know if
anything is gained by talking about
areta instead of virtue or
eudaimonia instead of happiness you know
unless you explain what the term
actually
signifies
i tend to like to
on use both the the greek and uh in
english translation so that if they side
by side
yeah so like you know um
uh
like you die don't you die money or
happiness and or um um
what is it flourishing human flourishing
yeah or all just because none of the
like our idea of happiness doesn't
actually encompass what you know
what you're talking about when you're
talking about eudaimonia
um at least in the the general sense and
so yeah kind of like happiness is like
just a psychological state that could
you know be fleeting and stuff like that
yeah yeah and which is quite different
like what what is stoic happiness in
this regard right like what what is
that that well-being of a human
like being excellent as a human and the
feeling of being excellent as a human
you know these are they're kind of deep
topics and and yeah i absolutely agree
like without proper
discussion you're you're just going to
talk over people that's right yeah
you know another lesson i'm going to
jump down a little bit we we actually
compiled a long list and i don't think
we're going to get to all of them um
this is one that was actually sent to me
in an email shortly after the conference
and it was it was from somebody who
self-identifies as a hardcore stoic and
who
has a pretty significant place within
let's call it this the stoic community
and he wrote me and he said one of the
things that i learned from the
discussions going on in the panel
was stoicism isn't necessarily for every
situation i thought that stoicism was
you know because it's a philosophy is a
way of life so it should be good for
everything right
and i thought that was a really
interesting insight
i don't think it diminishes stoicism to
say that you don't need to always bring
up stoicism
i i think in some ways it actually makes
it more effective if you can tell the
difference between
when classic stoic philosophy is going
to help you and when when it's actually
going to be
potentially a hindrance or or at least
just not particularly helpful
right um so you know examples of this
um definitely like in like a direct
example is um you
uh
it's like like a lot of the things that
stoicism gives you is feel more calm
mind you like a lot of these
psychological benefits they're in
um but that's not gonna really help you
if you're like
got a chemical imbalance or you're like
bipolar or something there's there's
something there you can't just you know
think your way out of that like
situation yeah and no matter how many
like
stoic quotes you post on your
refrigerator or make affirmations
you've still got a an issue that you
have to deal with perhaps with
medication or psychotherapy or
something like that i mean stoicism can
be it can be useful in telling you you
have a choice about how you
look at the situation but you you don't
choose to not
you you can't you can choose to not have
that problem but it that choice is going
to be totally ineffective you know
so
um you know stoicism also requires
modifying habits it's not like you can
have uh
a bad habit of you know a bad temper or
something then snap your fingers and
suddenly
you're calm all the time or anything
like that i think a lot of people
interpret
stoicism and it's not just stoicism
people do this with yoga people do this
with um
you know mindfulness meditation they
they want to treat it as if it's the
one-size-fits-all solution for
everything
um and it's a panacea exactly yeah
something that heals everything right
and it's just that's just not the case
it's really helpful and
i want to see what you think about this
idea i i want to say that
philosophies as ways of life that are
well structured that have been thought
out for a long time that have practices
and you know modes of development stuff
like that
they are more effective when we use them
say 90 percent of the time rather than
100 percent of the time
what do you think about that idea
this
so it kind of reminds me of
overfitting
machine learning there's a concept of
overfitting so you'll take
um
a data set and you're going to train
this machine learning model on
um and if you get the model to return
like a correct answer 99.5 percent of
the time yeah with your training data
then there's a very high likely um
chance that when you actually throw in
new novel general data
um to the model the model is going to
perform
poorly because it is over fit to the
small
subset of data that you already given it
um and so there's definitely a like you
don't want it to overfit too much and so
we're
the idea here would be we're trying to
um
shove everything into the stoic box in
every situation
when
the stoke box knight might not be the
optimum solution
for that particular issue
that's a that's a really interesting
analogy um
i could you know it's i when you were
talking about that i was thinking about
the person who goes to the gym
and they
they have certain exercises that they
like doing
and they only do those exercises right
so they get really really good at
benching you know but they don't do
other things that they they ought to be
doing to strengthen their body and then
they try to do something like help
somebody move right and and when you're
helping somebody move nothing fits the
way it's supposed to you don't have
ideal situations like laying flat
perfectly you know with the bar at a you
know 90 degree angle or anything like
that everything's screwed up
and
you could be really strong and be able
to
do great things with the leg press and
the bench and all these sorts of things
and yet
throw your back out or whatever else
you're going to do helping somebody
move because you've you've made your
body really good at certain things but
the world isn't quite like that
yeah maybe a more
mundane
uh analogy is you know
when you have a hammer everything looks
like a nail yeah yeah
yeah and stoicism so this is actually a
great segue into talking about something
else that um came up a lot in the panels
which is stoicism shouldn't be reduced
down to like you're saying down to just
one tool one one hammer the one that
people do that with the most is one
you've already mentioned that the
dichotomy of control which is making the
distinction between things that are in
our control which we should be occupied
with and care about things that are
outside of our control which we should
recognize as being outside of our
control
and yes that's a really important stoic
idea although as people pointed out i
think it was actually massimo pigliucci
who pointed this out or john sellers
that is an idea that only gets
formulated
very late in stoicism with epictetus so
clearly the earlier stoics didn't think
it was quite so important is that they
thought other ideas were
or at least equally or perhaps more
important
and
i i think you know if if we use the
exercise program thing again
you know are you better off like having
three or four exercises that you do all
the time and you get really good at
or should you be cross-training should
you be
learning how to use your body in all
sorts of different ways well stoicism is
doing that in terms of your your mind
your capacity for
choosing and prioritizing
and your emotions and your habits and
all these other things and so
we probably need to have a lot of
different exercises
and a lot of different concepts and the
ancient stoics did you know i mean
seneca when he's asked by somebody to
give quotes he's like i can't give you
any quotes because it's all good it's
all you know
you're like asking me to find you know
in a field uh you know the things that
are standing out they're all you know
tip top
so
although he does relent eventually yeah
all right dummy i'll give you i'll give
you some quotes
um
but
i think there's something i really think
there's something to this it doesn't i
think some people could get discouraged
they'd be like oh man i just started
learning this and now somebody's telling
me i got to learn like 10 times more
that could be demoralizing if you choose
to let it be demoralizing or you could
be like oh man
this is great i like this concept here i
can't wait till i learn all the other
concepts and they all fit together like
a cool
network or
something it looks like you just use the
concept of reframing
[Laughter]
um
but yeah like
this is one of the big things that like
stoicism talks sometimes about like
uh
some main practices being like three
legs of a tripod that they are held up
by each other and that no individual one
of these things
is going to be like your be all end-all
this is the difference between
you know seeing
uh stoicism as like a life act versus a
philosophy for life that the philosophy
of life is
the whole
group working in concert together
whereas if you're going to go and just
take like that dichotomy of control
which is like
it's been
touted about especially um with modern
stoicism as as one of the main things
that like people talk about early on
um it is can be incredibly useful but it
also
results in this issue that i've called
the stoic trap
and i've given a what's that i bought it
so i gave a presentation on this to the
stoke on brazil last year um and so the
stoic trap is this idea of kind of the
apathy that arises from one who takes on
the dichotomy of control too
much and so they go like well that
thing's not in my control
and so i'm not going to care about it at
all um and yeah
and then i become apathetic i'm not
going to do anything in the world to
make anything better and i feel like i
have no
uh obligation
to anyone else but the problem here is
that stoicism you know all the ancient
stokes talk about you know working in
harmony with all of your other you know
fellow band that we are you know working
together like you know uh two feet two
hands two rows of teeth upper and lower
to you know quote marcus aurelius and
um if you're using
the dichotomy of control to
remove yourself from the community of
other rational beings then you're not
practicing stoicism and so what the
point here is that the dichotomy of
control allows you to focus on
things that are the most important and
these include
on your community
and your fellow man
and to know the things that you can do
to
make that a better place
for all these people not to say oh
it's off my shoulders
i can't touch it anymore i can't do
anything that's not in my entire control
but what is in your entire control
um especially at this point in time in
the world where you know we live in
uh more of a democracy than you got in
rome with the caste system there that we
actually have some
um we have greater influence that
doesn't mean that
we can control things entirely but we
can do actions that do have influence in
the world
it's very interesting because you're
you're
in effect saying that something that
gets looked at as perhaps the
quintessential stoic practice
can be
non-stoic when it's done wrong
correct yeah or if you use it by itself
yeah yeah i think that makes a lot of
sense
um
we're getting close to the end so i i
think we can maybe fit in
one more
before we have to wrap it up and so if i
had to pick one other lesson it would be
if you build it they will come
but you have to build it right and you
have to promote it right especially if
it's an online conference
so
you know we were really fortunate in
that we had about as many people this
time around as we did last year it was a
great success people really liked it but
there are some things that we need to do
different like building in breaks
you know
maybe having even more variety
in the formats we did a workshop and
lightning talks and panels and
a lot of talks and like on a keynote
address maybe we need to do some some
other things but i mean the cool thing
is if you do
if you do put together something
um and you get the word out there people
are hungry for this sort of intellectual
and practical engagement
what do you think is there anything else
to say about that or should we
jump right into our final
quote we've got a moment here i guess um
once again like what uh greg and andy
did that they're great planning um to
make sure that all the speakers were
there to figure out how to run the
moderation in the
comments to
build out the breakout rooms there was
lots of
emails back and forth with all the
presenters and the newer ones what's up
helpers yeah
um to to make sure that these things and
so it's just making sure that
uh everyone's on the same page is uh
something that uh greg and andy did
quite well so oh thanks for all you for
all you aspiring uh
runners of conferences
well i think we have to end on our our
final
thoughts
in respect to running conferences we
leave you with the words of massimo
pilutschi one of the first lessons from
stoicism then is to focus our attention
and efforts where we have most power and
then let the universe run as it will
this will save us both
a lot of energy and a lot of worry
[Music]
you